le projet a lu dans de nombreux parcs et
en collaboration avec les parcs éoliens
à l'espace rambouillet ces quatre
espèces de rapaces qui ont été étudiés
dans le cadre du projet map dont cet
aigle blessé par une éolienne
on vient ici pour étudier certaines
espèces notamment l'aigle royal qu'on a
ici derrière pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce qui fait que les rapaces ne
voit pas les éoliennes et qui fait
qu'ils rentrent en collision avec les
élèves le principe est simple l'oiseau
est soumis à un test et ses mouvements
de tête sont étudiées pour que les
chercheurs puissent identifier les
contrastes ok ils réagissent c'est un
test qui est très simple qui est non
invasif on aime bien le préciser c'est à
dire qu'il ya pas de contrainte pour
l'oiseau l'oiseau est juste présenté
devant des écrans donc dans une boîte
transparente présenté devant des écrans
il ya huit écrans autour d'elle autour
de l'oiseau pardon micro autour de
l'oiseau et on met un pattern qu'on
appelle un gros lifting qui est une
alternance de barres noires et de barbe
blanche et on le fait bouger soit vers
la gauche vers la droite
des études d'impact ainsi que des
systèmes de détection des oiseaux et
d'arrêt des éoliennes sont mis en place
par les parcs éoliens et premières
études qui ont été faites ont montré que
les oiseaux en une capacité de
perception du contraste qui est à peu
près 10 fois inférieure à la nôtre
donc c'est vraiment très faibles donc si
on voit que ça se généralise chez la
plupart des oiseaux et notamment les
réseaux qui sont concernés par les
collégiens que les éoliennes on pourra
dire que le contrat c'est certainement
un facteur qui fait que les oiseaux
rentrer en collision avec les éoliennes
et si c'est ça on pourra agir derrière
au terme de cette étude des solutions
seront envisagées pour pallier cette
mortalité comme par exemple le peindre
certaines pas l'éolienne en noir ou y
ajouter des motifs